yeah yeah we're good to start
yeah yeah chin we're good to start we're
just yelling at us
i want to start this this way i'm going
to bad mood i took my pants off took my
i was going to take a shower i pull my
you know how when you pull your
underwear off and something my girl goes
oh you got a dingle
and my dick it wasn't a dick my dick was
you know sometimes your dick has been
bunched up so it's yeah but your balls
are tight
yeah and you're doing this
it's kind of hiding now so honestly
yeah yeah it looks like a little boom
like this like the foot turtle yeah a
cold turkey it's not a dick it's a
dingle
it's a single thing i said you got a
little yeah you have a dingo i go hey
yeah don't say it tell him about the
yeah tell her to choose the difference
but don't look at it like this yeah i
gotta let it let the heat get to it she
could have been like gotta warm up
yep that's better you gotta
dragon taking a little nappy poo oh and
this was at the top of the morning the
eel decided to take a little nappy nap
today yeah that'd be more refreshing yep
that's way better dragon though i like
did you wake him up
i got to slap him you gotta stop him
around a little bit gotten the shower
slightly in that hot shower get the warm
water get it get the veins came back out
and i go can i help you yep
there you go everything all right keep
that same energy [ __ ] yep keep that
same
now look at this [ __ ]
dingle
you want to call this guy a dingle yeah
put you in a bad mood huh
it is what it is bro yeah
well it's going to be annoying i can't
tell you how many people ask me at the
thick mudder why you're not there
i'll go i'll come i don't think so brian
i can run right
i told him you could do five my feet are
bad 15k is not i was just like i
honestly he's just
and i'm not even trying to be funny it's
just i think 15k at your age it would be
dangerous
it's not dangerous i think i have the i
i played two hours of volleyball and
then two hours before that i'm i can
handle i think men at 55 of you if
you're in shape you can run nine miles i
don't think so oh i know i know i can
run i might might want to but you
haven't been running
you would have to be a consistent runner
but that's this [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying the body breaks
out even my body like yeah on mile seven
i always tell them like here we go
something's gonna start cramping you
gotta fight through it right like the
inside of my thighs were camping my
[ __ ] calf was cramping yeah every
everyone like in these guys are in shape
and they run they're cramping yeah and
they're like man how come i'm calm i'm
like these 50 [ __ ] something years
old
nine miles he's not even trained for
like it's kind of got a train for it
yeah it's kind of dude i don't run
i could i think the five mile either the
five the 5k the 5k no the 5k is only
three yeah i might try the 5k it's like
anything else my dad's my dad's gonna do
it yeah my dad's next one i think next
one might be in chicago literally the
only thing i worry about is this this
area it gets [ __ ] and i'm telling you
it's gonna be a problem like mitrione
crazy ass friday when he lands he's like
dude you're doing the thick mutter i'm
like yeah dude he's like i want in
okay have you been running it was no and
then
and then i go just sign up here and i'll
cover whatever you need he's like cool
he goes hold up 15k how far is that says
a little over nine miles he goes nah
[ __ ] this and now you have fun just do
it he's like yeah i have arthritis and
that's something he needs to have knee
surgery because bone on bone and when
he's telling me also like there's no way
this dude's gonna make it so we start
running we start and i told the crew
it's me mark and all these other guys
and we're leading the pack and i go
we're going too fast i'm telling you
it's it's a marathon we're going way too
fast we left everybody i can tell matt's
starting to like get yeah
obviously
matt knows this i'm not throwing any
shade at matt i looked at chrome it's
gonna be a long day if matt does the all
the [ __ ] race because we get to wait
for him you know because he hasn't been
running yeah yeah how did you do this
second time around yeah yeah what was
your third time around our third time
way better yeah way better way better
and i'm not even like i'm sorry
no i was just more tired because it was
94 degrees out there how hot it got it
was so hot my face got burnt mark ran
without a shirt and i told mark halfway
through i'm like dude you're purple
you're gonna be [ __ ] tomorrow
it was fun though yeah you guys finished
this all the time nine miles yeah
fashion the first time that's good it's
no joke no but it's just fun yeah it's
just fun
it's really fun so wait you would do
that you would do the the 5k which is
like three jay and my dad are going to
do it
my only worry is my my calves and my
ankles you could do the yeah guarantee
it i fixed my foot like two and a half
miles but remember it's not really two
and a half miles because you're adding
in obstacles and you're waiting yeah i
can do that
it's different i feel like yeah you
would have to like consistently because
my adopted father he's 52 and he runs
like no other he does marathons like
it's your body but
that's what he's always done though yeah
you know but if you if you don't do that
then me and mark harley halfway through
i was like we're at the top of the
mountain it's [ __ ] gorgeous i'm
trying to
halfway through that's when you're kind
of you guys run up a mountain you're
kind of like [ __ ] this here's where they
changing that's why i told the boys
because our first one we ran was at the
same uh glen helen raceway and the first
one we started off it was just an
incline for four miles it's a horrible
way to start this time we went around
that and kind of gradually worked up and
i said i'm telling you man we're going
too fast i guarantee you they're going
to add in that deep incline but it's
going to be at the end i'm telling you
don't waste your [ __ ] energy on this
yep and like oh we're fine like we're
going too fast man you got to pump the
brakes
sure enough mile 6 you hit it boom the
incline starts [ __ ] but then we get to
the top and i looked at everyone because
that's when everyone starts kind of
mentally like dude what are we doing we
have [ __ ] three more
that's when your body starts to break
down yeah like it's more mental than
anything like you can power through it i
just told i looked at mark i'm like dude
how [ __ ] it's saturday dude look at
this like the views dope i told mark i'm
like i love this [ __ ] so much i said
because he's the only friend i have
who's down to do the weird athletic [ __ ]
that like i like to do i said i'd be
down to train for a uh ultra uh yeah
ultra marathon yes
mark can swim too oh yeah
for a bodybuilder to have that kind of
endurance is pretty unbelievable oh dude
when we went on the thing where you got
like
there's like green water freezing water
underneath you gotta climb and hit this
thing and [ __ ] do it oh like the spin
he jumps on there you know he's a lot
dude he's his shirts off and his ass is
hanging out everyone's waiting you know
like these smaller people are waiting
he's like
and last time he fell off so he was like
so adamant to make sure he could do it
yeah yeah and last time he made it to
the very end then slipped into the water
so he said i gotta redeem myself i gotta
do this because i guess people were like
hating on him online about not finishing
it so he gets up then he's going i share
one guy back oh look at his lats
it's just like
wings just
purple
massive man just gliding through did he
make it he made it oh good good i feel
like he his bone structure can carry
that kind of muscle it's like he's
cardio for dinner yeah he's crazy he's
right there with me he has a lot more
muscle than i do that's i was looking at
him because i was behind my one time
like how the [ __ ] does his body get
through all this he seems pretty light
on his feet you don't have that he don't
have injuries like he doesn't really
cramp up he's gonna do well in the cold
crazy strong yeah yeah he does not do
well in the cold his legs are [ __ ]
stupid
it was [ __ ] hot out there man i bet
and they left 94 94 the whole time and
they let my pops go on the the atv with
kyle and mike's my dad was just driving
them around mm-hmm my dad thought it'd
be funny grab a wood stick and try and
shock me on purpose i was like yeah
we'll straight up fight you does it does
it end with the shocking yeah the shock
thing or
whatever that's so funny look at him how
[ __ ] huge mark is look at how big
matt is matt's actually bigger than mark
he weighs more for sure yeah yeah that's
what 285 he said he's about 280 yeah
because we had to do this thing we got
to carry each other and uh mark was like
i'll do matt and i was like i'll need me
and mark both down for the cut i was
like i might you can jump my back and
matt went i'm turning eighty pounds man
i'll see you guys at the other end
just walking by are you straight you're
stronger than matt lifting wise oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but he does it he'll tell
like he said on the campaign he's not
like weight room strong right he's yeah
functional he's a monster functionally
like his hips and legs
his arm like he's a monster but like in
the weight room it's just it was never
crazy afterwards i don't think he did
225 that many times for the combine
right maybe 18 which is great it's so
much for a guy like me though yeah i saw
you messing around with them 18 and 18
in uh
comment his position is awful well when
when you [ __ ] around with your my size
joking around with a guy like matt yeah
and like you're joking around wrestling
wise you have to actually be careful
even when they're [ __ ] around because
if matt matt went you ready ready
because he was going to pull me in real
quick i saw that yeah like that
that can [ __ ] you up if you're a regular
guy you have to be really careful it's
all fun again when matt cracked our back
oh dude
so matt goes i'm the best at cracking
back so we're all like hell yeah dude
let's do this look at that uh i got the
high color that's why they call him meat
heck his head so big yeah because he's
an actual meathead he's fast here look
at this here
that right there and i was like okay
okay don't pull me in don't pull me in i
love how you guys are both in jeans and
things yeah that's sam what are you
saying he uh he's like oh i'm really
good at cracking bats okay like nobody
can crack my back so i watched him
brian's like do mine but he like
he grabs you so you're facing you're
both facing forward so he's behind you
and then you just like he's just
dropping your hips drop your hips and
then he like jacks you up you can bring
back us
and i was like oh and then brian goes oh
man she felt good i was like oh i wanted
i didn't tell you he didn't tell me dude
there's the muscle oh my god it can't be
safe i think i think i might be broken
for life but then it came back but it's
just like it just sounded like it's the
way he like
i already ended up feeling really good
later so yeah
same thing
and i was like
oh
and you felt like
he's not a doctor yeah not as a kid he's
a professional in it he had an actual
chiropractor there that other dude that
came with mark oh right yeah that guy
yeah oh that uh that dude from atlanta
yeah yeah yeah yeah cool kid yeah he ran
with us yeah oh he did he did with us
yeah i think he played pro baseball for
a while no uh-oh no no not pro no it's
semi-pro
no i think he played uh like double a or
whatever yeah well right what's
that playable or doubles played in the
brewers uh with the burritos for he did
yeah he played pro though he didn't make
it to the maid i don't think he made it
to all the way that made him play it in
there like what's the next level like
the feeder like the farmer yeah like
double a or absolutely yeah either way
even if you're single or double you must
be looking good yeah
good but he's pretty he's pretty strong
too he should have cracked our back
[Laughter]
look man hey b look man i'm gonna be in
phoenix this is thursday friday saturday
that would be intense end up live dude
you love stand up
yeah i'm there with the thick boy crew
this thursday friday saturday at stand
up live in phoenix and you're going to
be in tampa yeah so if you're tampa
improv if you're in the phoenix tampa
area you can see stand up come on down
f a t k z dot com or bigboy.com the next
weekend i'm in port charlotte at the
vasani theater where are you i'm glad
you asked i'm at i'm doing the paramount
theater for the the moon tower comedy
festival we moved from cap cities
because your boys are moving tickets
we're at the paramount theater one show
one night only april 23rd moon tower
economy festival come see the thick boy
squad live in person at the paramount
theater austin texas april 23rd now
you're special there's a rumor your
special drops april 29th april 28th oh
28th you can watch on 29th too
i don't care yeah either or pick your
poison yep the gringo poppy special
drops on thick boy youtube april 28th
get you some
now b listen
people don't always realize physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
oh it's
stress you mean what stress does to you
the physical stuff the stress does dude
hey you're cracking your teeth you know
that i went i am going to go here clinch
and you're good
dude stress shows up in all kinds of
ways and in a world that's telling you
to do more sleep less grind all the time
sleep four hours here's your reminder
take care of yourself folks take care of
yourself do less and you know what maybe
try some therapy how about that well you
work out you work your body out
sometimes you got to take care of your
brain you want to feel better get with a
real licensed professional dude i'm
talking about better help all right it's
online therapy that offers video phone
even live chat sessions with a therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to if you're
shy it's a lot more affordable than
in-person therapy that's the thing so
you give it a try see if online therapy
can help lower your stress i tell you
what it always helps me it always helps
me man this podcast is sponsored by
better help and fighter and the kid
listeners and viewers get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com fighter
that's better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash fighter for 10 off your
first month
better help better help look man
i i gotta tell you i can't eat all my
vegetables all the time you're on the
carnivore diet but that doesn't mean you
don't get your your greens i got to get
my greens thank god today's podcast is
brought to you by athletic greens and
specifically ag-1 by athletic greens
it's a superfood dude it's a super food
it is it contains 1775 give it to them
75 vitamins minerals whole foods food
sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more and it's
all in one one daily
serving it's i i know too many people
who are high functioning people that
swear by this i swear by it yeah one one
little scoop and eight ounces of water
you chug that thing down you feel like
hulk hogan yep yep like young hulk not
dude like a young like a young hogan
look but by the way
whether you're an athlete like you're a
mom whether you're a dad first-timer it
doesn't matter you will get all your
essential nutrition from one scoop and
i'll give you a free one year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit athletics
athletic greens.com
fighter athletic greens.com fighter
that was so funny dude picking them up
and my my dad goes we're taking my
bronco to the uh san bernardino okay
it's two hour drive and my dad goes oh
matt you're too big i'll jump in the
back because my broncos two doors so my
dad jumps in the back and then matt
jumps on the front he's like how are you
doing pops dude from the how you doing
pops till we
stop driving
he didn't shut his mouth
matt will talk
he's nobody responded got a lot to say
too matt's going to look oh really
go man does he not live here no oh yeah
no
always entertaining every time i go to
he's the best he rolls with the two-ton
club so it's like the biggest dudes
you've ever seen haystack uh his other
buddy uh black guy they're all all
feeling they're all good just a huge
[ __ ] great guys
they're all [ __ ] great yeah just
every time we go we hang it's they're
all [ __ ] fight companion was good
though yeah so much fun we had a little
time at the end but also the fight was
so dominant there's not much for us to
talk about you know we got a little
tired josh thompson's got a great jaw on
him he's a good-looking kid yeah like
i'm looking at his face and i looked at
myspace and i go what happened
what happened to my round that's so
broad
that is [ __ ] sad
brian looks homeless like
dude that's how that is i'll just help
them out what happened to my face my
face when i was younger was not bad this
looks like a make-a-wish thing oh my god
no hair thing doesn't help me
just an egghead are you looking tough
why don't you smile in the picture no
bro because i had my braces in who knows
why who cares
it wouldn't have made a difference and
that's just [ __ ] those giants i think
being next to josh thompson like [ __ ]
you up for this picture handsome i think
that's what [ __ ] you up otherwise and
josh is 44 he says and matt's 44 too
yeah yeah mma royalty what josh has his
own gym right or something
yeah yeah yeah he's great you talking
about a guy who had 47 mma fights that's
a different dude
oh yeah josh is great different dude
josh is great and he'll give you the
he's good for the command you know i
like to [ __ ] around i'll talk mma
obviously but yeah will you know just
talk he'll get deep yeah he gets d yeah
he can tell you what the guy should be
doing right there yeah do you have any
um
do you have any further thoughts on
kamza what you saw and all that stuff i
think yeah i think he lived did you
watch it uh no just like that i think he
lived up to the hype you know
ranked number 11 jumping all the way to
two which is unheard of yeah so
obviously he's he's he's as advertised
as the test but his coach you know i
mean chin talked about on the shop show
his coach came out and said like
you know people asking what i said
during the second round and like i tore
in i'm like dude quit [ __ ] fighting
like you're in a street fight like use
your length make it boring yeah use your
reach like he was he had no game plan
you're just in there to fight yeah and
when you get to a certain level and
thank god it worked against gilbert but
that ain't working against colby or
camaro you gotta you have to have a game
plan so that is the fight
him and colby next or whatever uh that's
what dana wants that dana said colby and
hans out of fight on abc
the issue with that is uh kobe wants to
get paid
like they're gonna happen and that's not
a big payday for him no it'd be a big
payday especially on abc hopefully they
would up his pay but he just demands
more money so there's going to be a bit
of you should demand more money yeah but
the problem with that is you'll see okay
we'll have somebody else fight him you
don't want to do it on abc but i hope
they figure it out because dude colby
who's the ultimate heel is going to get
usa
yeah
and take my money even though it's free
on abc but take my money colby correct
because there's nobody better to play
this game and also
you know before that fight hamza didn't
have any [ __ ] in his armor nobody
wanted to fight him that's why i had to
fight number two guy they didn't want to
give him number two but nobody would
fight oh [ __ ] so
gilbert's like i'll do it so ufc is like
[ __ ] it let's see what happens he passed
the test
but you know i think if you're colby or
camaro now you're going i'll fight that
guy for five rounds
because that fourth and fifth can get
dicey for me especially fights like that
so if you're a hamza fan which i am you
gotta hope he learned from that like oh
i can't fight like this all the time and
also i think you overlook gilbert
because he's sitting on the cage
chilling i'm like whoa dude number two
guy for a reason i said it yeah you said
it i was like watching him kick talk and
i'm like you don't look like you're
you're taking gilbert burns lightly i
know like you don't get to be number two
like without nobody dude he just he's
not that far
uh you know when he was fighting kamar
was going for a world championship and
rock tomorrow yeah he did i watched that
fight before this one yeah no he's not
yeah and and homside hasn't really done
much in the ufc so to me i was like ah
man he's kind of buying the hype yeah
and his coach said that he's like
his coach yeah his coach said that he's
like we had a game plan he he just
fought like scrapped like you're just
trying to scrap and you can't do that
but thank god he passed you know got
passed yeah twenty nine twelve so how do
you think he would do against colby then
it'd be
if if that if he does did the exact same
thing he did on saturday night he'll
always [ __ ] yeah yeah kobe beats him
by decision
but i don't think he will i think he'll
learn from him and get better
so we'll see damn it's fun though yeah
who's the better striker
comes up
probably right it's tough that no i
don't know colby's can [ __ ] strike
without him he has a gas tank for days
you're not taking colby down never been
taken down you're not taking him down no
all-american from oregon state coley's a
monster
uh yeah yeah so you know
but but i think if hamza uses reach it
won't be the most exciting fight it's
all right but you can win dude yeah
but if that same hamza showed up against
camaro colby he wouldn't he wouldn't it
comes out of natural 85
i don't know like gilbert's a pretty
juicy 170 pounder but it's not like
comes out had reach and uh hide but he
wasn't like
no well he looked skinny actually i mean
he wasn't like thin yeah yeah so they
were trying to compete at both but i
just think it's interesting my my larger
question is
when he would he's got that great jab
and he exchanged
up and then when when he would in the
transition so boom boom boom he's hit
when he looks right
that's what he said right i went you're
resetting but you don't you're getting
caught he's still in the pocket yes
you're getting caught in the pocket so
so bob bob he would he would like
counter and then uh gilbert would come
back with that and he was getting
clipped almost everywhere that's what
his coach said like you shouldn't be in
there dude right you should be outside
using your reach and height advantage
right which he didn't and that's what
that the game plan was right that's why
it's cool don't stand in the pockets
coach was so upset right
damn
yeah i wonder why he went in this coach
said use your reach okay do you think
that peter yan won that fight i heard a
lot of people no not at all no
no and what now again i went
balls deep in this in the shop showing
her in the paint on it's it's no
i have no ill will towards dana but when
dana is watching at cage side and then
does the press conference and goes they
got it wrong on that one without
watching it like we see it again
again
you're you [ __ ] your champion over now
there's still that yeah dark child over
algebraic now you didn't really beat
them even your boss doesn't think you
did it's not how'd your main beat him i
watched i watched it this morning i
watched it yesterday out so the way you
break that fight down
is it's five rounds right first round is
the is the deciding factor the sound
factor second round clearly
clearly
no i'm not even close yeah to me that's
why i even said you could do ten eight
if you want i'm not mad at you 1080 so
dominant 10-8
only because he had him had his back but
he didn't do a lot he didn't do a lot of
damage sure but he just dominated yes
like he'd literally dominate the entire
round third round dominate and tie
around so second third there's no
argument anybody on the planet knows he
won't say third uh fourth
yawn all day for sure yeah fifth close
but you let's give it to peter so it's
all in the first [ __ ] round yeah the
first round based off the scoring
criteria
people are going to give it to yon going
octagon control aggressiveness yeah but
what's his name hold on
but that's the that's the
the like big john had to break because i
should always say that too here's the
aggressor this big john goes hold up
that's the last thing that you judge of
brown off of is octagon control right
before that there must be damage done
strikes landed so i'm going based off
the
where jacksonville florida commission
where they do judging based off their
judging which is what we have the only
way to go off of
al germain landed more strikes
actually no uh period allen added more
significant strikes bring that up gin he
did he landed two kills he won like he
won to 40. he
yeah but 51 to 46 i think but but but
having said that al jamaine tried to
take him down 22 times to zero that's
but that's you're talking about the
overall fight i'm talking about just the
first round okay that's all we care
about this whole fight is predicated on
oh let's see
and that's why i'm saying algerian did
more in the first round he's more active
oh wow you can't go oh well he was on
his back foot the whole round well i
agree that doesn't that's that that's
his style 100 you can't base the round
off that
that's interesting yeah the first round
then so
so two judges had it for sterling in the
first round of course
but they don't but uh do copy strike
numbers for that first round
chin okay
[Music]
is company strike
stats
is that it right there too it's a second
it's just all japanese but i'll check it
out oh
here we are yeah
so first round strikes
so so
uh yeah well that's overall though
so strikes
is six two six three take down two you
gotta give it so you you gotta
ultimately but i need it by the round
you know what i'm saying
does that say here we go
so red's al germain so round one he
landed 19 of 40. wow john landed 13 of
26.
so
again i'm going off the florida state
commission yeah that's a win rules
so he landed more did more damage more
significant strikes 17 of 29 so 58
percent of strikes to the body that's
second round to that second round all
right round two yeah
and then
i'm sorry
why are you going off why do you have to
go with the first round because
everything else is clear as day oh got
it second third is al jermaine the
fourth is john all day fifth
close but i'd let's give it to jan so
young won two out of three it's very
evident
but again what [ __ ] al jermaine is dana
gunn judge got wrong on that one without
looking at the actual numbers just being
kate's side watching on that little
shitty screen it's like dude you [ __ ]
them now now the same narrative you're
not the real champion when the guy
deserves it he beat him yeah
based off of i agree your calculations
your judging criteria al james one
that's not a huge 35er that would be
yeah i would be interested in seeing
algerman going up to 45 and fighting uh
our boy uh volcano
what do you think of that
he's not that big of a 35er but
santa hagan's a big 35. i feel like he's
bigger than san diego he's not as tall
saying he's taller but he's thick
especially in that fight he looked thick
it's tough you always want people to go
up being it it's tough man you know it's
tough
because you have to you have to talk
about the stretch the strength advantage
and there's also there's a lot of work
for him to do at 35.
you just got the belt and barely got it
yeah
because you click the only the only time
you're going to jump is if you're like
conor mcgregor or izzy and you're just
dominating and you're like a massive
star or you've cleaned out the division
yeah there's a lot of work to do yeah
yeah there are a lot of killers he can't
jump he's got a face [ __ ] tj dylan
tj is fighting next right yeah
that's a great fight who's he fighting
oh [ __ ]
made of different cloth
yeah i can't wait
yeah hopefully all jermaine doesn't just
harp on the you know fail the drug test
while it's like dude get over it
wait that's what every fighter is going
to say it's just about when they oh when
they talk about tj stop peter young's
never been busted stop though yeah
yeah so hopefully they don't just harp
on that
um how was your weekend in uh salt lake
it was great it's all nice
great club right great club man you've
been there before this is amazing yeah
yeah and so he booked me based off of
that yep shouts out i appreciate the
love yeah
hey books be based off of uh opening
hopefully
uh in vegas night yeah he talked about
we talked about that yeah i'll be there
again he says it's uh
he loves the setup and what they're
doing with it over there what is it what
is it like you've done it yeah they it's
a small room small room yeah yeah great
good location it's like the hipster part
right by yeah
is what he said okay he says about one
150
all right uh cap yeah or whatever it's a
good especially for vegas but yeah you
don't you do it thursday too thursday
friday yeah and especially if you do
more with locals than you do with
like yeah instead of competing with the
strip actually yeah you ever done one of
those crazy vegas weeks you've done one
before not a week i've just done it's
like
through yeah did you do i used to do the
playboy club
at the palms yeah when it was a thing i
know that oh yeah playboy like it was
they had their own club in there oh it
was pretty well and they had their own
like what stand-up room or something a
great room and really yeah
but you never have to do tuesday through
sunday no sir no like a lot of those
vegas it was like a week through sundays
that's so
crazy room they would always they still
call me about that i still do it yeah
yeah i'm not that is
[ __ ] saying
yeah you'd have to pay me you know i
mean i guess
i'm not doing it awful i'll do it
carousel don't even do it every day
i think he does all right damn there you
go you know you've got a residency in in
vegas and they pay you that much money
that's hard to say no to you you're
working my homie went and saw karen top
he said
pretty damn good oh everyone
he's doing something pretty damn good
he's been there too long yeah bad yeah
he's a monster amazing i would how has
he had that residency because i used to
when i used to go to vegas for cheer
comps when i was like 15 you would see
carrot top being promoted
yep five year extension how long has you
been there 2015. he makes sense no it's
long like 2015. if you have bad life in
vegas everything is first class i mean
it's hard dude so that says 2015 it says
after a 10-year run so that would be
what [ __ ] 1995
you said he's done it for 10 years now
well this says
after a 10-year run and this is in 2000
so he started at 2005's this year oh
yeah that's when he started yeah yeah
wow that's a long time
dude it's working for that it's working
for him he's doing the goddamn thing
that might be just at that one place
though yeah he's iconic he doesn't use
radon daniel daniel tosh has a residency
in vegas i think it's a girl does
cigarettes
yep once a month damn
i think seinfeld did for a long time
and i hear they pay you [ __ ]
oh big dumb money yeah look at that
start times uh monday through saturday 8
p.m and that's where you worked with my
boy jimmy walker huh that's right
and he said was he talking crazy or
something i've been in this game a long
time i never heard of youtube
it was this it was
very interesting america's manager's
like come meet johnny walker he's like
i've been doing comedy for whatever he
said
never you two
and wouldn't look at us
he was headlining yeah no [ __ ] no he's
the opener then he goes uh it's not
1974. so
because i saw the flyer i said i'm
working with these guys and i said
i
know he did it yeah now i think a lot of
it's him being funny because he's oh was
he messing with you guys here's some
pictures of me that's guy that's david
letterman i don't know if you ever heard
of him i worked with him oh okay so he's
being [ __ ] around he's going through
like the old school [ __ ] yeah yeah so he
might he might be just a silly goose
those older guys i feel like are like
that where they kind of just like bust
your balls like
yeah in the no
i didn't i didn't get that vibe
to shake his hand and he goes don't
touch me yeah he's straight-up said that
yeah
and then i roasted him so make sure you
get your dvd's
signed jimmy walker
don't touch me you think he was kidding
no no no wait what are you saying you're
too nice you're too nice wait what'd you
say brian joking who jokes
it was just me and him bro like i want
to give everybody the benefit out of my
name no he wasn't
no no no he's a bit of an [ __ ] also
we didn't book him they forced us to use
it i would never book an 87 year old man
to open my show i'm going to [ __ ] how
long he's done it
he's in a tuxedo i'm like this is not
our vibe gosh so he was the host
yeah yeah
he's making survivor references no he
wasn't yeah star wars and survivor yeah
like the old survivor
and it's your guys's crown which is like
he went bad on him yeah it's fine we
don't want to go bad on him no that's a
good dude yeah
y'all have them over again probably yeah
mm-hmm dude people love my damn new
shoes by the way those are getting a lot
of likes oh a lot of likes what are
those every time i step out on stage
people like god damn what are those the
tangerine on there uh
oranges you like them brian i'll get you
a pair i like them what size do you
actually like them a lot you do really i
really do i would wear the [ __ ]
clothes
are they a lot of colors
you lift them up to the camera
thank you who makes them lakay
yeah get me something yeah i'll get you
a pair what size do you get ten and a
half
yeah of course give me how about those
you want eleven i mean they fit pretty
well to size yeah but i like a lot it's
definitely not sold out you want to just
order them yourself
[Applause]
you know but i i i thought you had them
hey no ever since i posted about getting
these so many people have been [ __ ]
getting them are they sold out they're
not sold out oh that's cool but i put
they but they've they were released a
while back but people are yeah i think i
put them back on the map you know put
them back on that's why they sent them
to you dude no they didn't send it i
bought them myself oh you bought them
yeah yeah yeah
i was in search for them because when i
saw them i was like damn i need those
bad and i thought they'd be hard to find
pretty easy yeah makes sense pretty easy
but you can't skateboard in those uh no
no these are fashion
well paddle board fashion right
you get paddle board in those like
you're not gonna skate but the escape
brand is escape brand
right yeah it's escape brand yes it's
escape right what do you but then
they're just for like chilling
yeah
oh those are cool those all orange ones
are dope
larry june and they're not tangerines
either no jin i thought
i said
june
uh right there to the right you see him
all those black ones are dope what black
ones
we'll go back as it loads
black ones these those those oh those
would be like oh yeah i should get those
two these orange ones are dope too these
are so guess what those are way doper
hey bro hey i bought a second pair do
you bought two of them yeah just because
you slipped them oh my gosh so right
they're actually really cool are they
dope yeah yeah i dig them
i'd wear them with a rope you want a
pair of two
i don't think so
i would wear the orange
and the black ones though i'd rock those
i like that color i like the black ones
too the black ones are sick you rock
those yeah i'd rock those
all right so brian you're getting
slip-ons bringing you're getting the
[ __ ] i'm gonna slip on but now if you
have to flip flop and slip on guy don't
pay for them
hopefully they are they like 20 bucks oh
[ __ ] you
i don't know i don't know if shoes why
would you why are you gonna buy me a
pair
all those are sick yeah they're not it's
70
hey i got a four thousand dollar guitar
collection i can afford if you get it
for free get them for me you don't have
to buy them i'll get them and who's
larry june he's a rapper out of the bay
area he's dope yeah he's cool those
clouds are dope the gun bottoms are
still god rock those
it's cool color ways
see
we got this
we're gonna be all fashioned up
we'll be fashioned up dude wait so you
really rock those ones yeah i'll rock
those yeah okay especially the gummy
yeah i didn't get you know for your
birthday
you didn't nope
that's not nice yeah and i didn't get
anything for his birthday either
january 26th nope 1967.
i remember birthdays hey how about i
made that charlie chaplin reference and
josh and matt thought i was dead serious
yeah brian opened for charlie chap
josh went wow damn that's funny guys
catch it no and i'm just staring like
together oh you guys think i'm serious
charlie chaplin did died in the 70s or
something yeah i mean at least
black lives matter
in 1981 that's so funny that they were
like oh
he did silent movies yeah
born in 1880 you were only 10 in 1977
yeah born in 18
89 yeah
he was a brilliant guy though that was
so [ __ ] funny that weird mustache but
he uh this is a big deal yeah
you know who's a big fan of them eddie
murphy yeah charlie chaplin yeah eddie
murphy loves mary a 13 year old girl
though yes he did
some young skeletons there was some some
weird [ __ ] that went on
with charlie
yeah i think she was impossibly young i
believe i don't know he had his house
off of uh laurel canyon there he did
yeah he was brilliant and he uh
republique which is my
one of my favorite restaurants in la top
three republic uh that's what was that
old that's his old offices right he
turned it yeah and it's beautiful yeah
he was a brilliant [ __ ] i read
his autobiography and he talks about
being poor he came over to hollywood to
make it big but because he's from really
he's he's british right out here uh yeah
he talked about it coming out here no at
first it didn't it didn't go well well
at first but he became he was huge
around the world at one point mm-hmm
yeah
yeah oh yeah he's from eighteen
he was knighted oh he's an english comic
actor i didn't know he's from england i
really didn't how old was he when he
died so 1889
he was good at math
i didn't know that he's from england
bubba i didn't know that yeah i know
he's english because have you seen
robert downey jr does the whole yeah
oh he lives a good life 88 [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
man that's a pretty cool way to die on
christmas day [ __ ] man
oh he was only 5'5 short king oh very
small i didn't know he's five four very
small yeah
and he may have been shorter than that
yeah his wife was competing to be live
wikipedia five five she's probably five
three christian got a new [ __ ]
north star by man yeah
yeah
charlie chaplin hell yeah now
you swear by peloton i love bikers
i think ass dude they got me started on
that that bike road life because i was
uh i've been a member of peloton for six
years now i thought you know what i
really enjoy this why don't i get a real
bike and get out tonight nature but now
man it's safer to just do it from the
the the from your garage dude
dude rattlesnakes cars people
from from your garage and they have
great instructors they keep you
motivated my favorite part is the music
they have new classes new music they've
also added boxing that's right you don't
have to have boxing gloves it's their
great peloton instructors in your corner
giving you the workout of your life plus
they got a variety you can do the
de-stress from a long day with a
30-minute strength workout 20 minutes of
cardio you can do a quick 50-minute
total body class yeah dude before work
again the music the from pop rock hip
hop edm they have over 100 artists
series to choose from you're gonna find
your favorite music to keep you grinding
the whole time visit onepeleton.com to
learn more that's
onepelton.com o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
the nba playoffs mean next level
basketball
get ready for an all
action all action by betting the play in
tournament with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the nba
new customers come at five dollars on
any team to win and get 150 dollars in
free bets instantly you clinch a win no
matter what all draftkings sportsbook
customers can also bet on nba hoops with
the same game parlays combine multiple
bets from the same game for a bigger
payout the more legs you add the more
money can win plus for each day of the
play-in get a risk-free bet up to ten
dollars if your same game parlay doesn't
hit download draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter bet
five dollars on any nba team to win
their game during the play-in tournament
and get 150 dollars in free bets
instantly that's promo code fighter at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
brand partner of the nba minimum age and
eligibility restriction supply see show
note for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer download
draftking sportsbook app now promo code
fighter
where's the republic at ryan it's right
on uh la brea it have you been there i
don't know before yeah
it's so impossibly good i can't even
tell you it's sick republicans look at
that restaurant it's it is those were
his offices you don't get better food oh
is that off wilshire yeah no yeah yeah
we'll share it yeah yeah dude that's you
guys
all the time
you don't get better food that place is
packed
it's a husband and wife team she won an
award for desserts is that them right
there she wanted yeah she won an award
for desserts like a james beard award
for desserts and he won for cooking
they're both monsters and they collabed
damn
i mean great dessert they're very
special people have you been there their
steak their steak is the best steak i've
ever had in my [ __ ] life ryan let's
go there yeah we should and charlie
chaplin's offices are upstairs there's
that whole building he's saying that see
how that's a courtyard that used to be
that was wasn't covered but back in the
day so that was like the street and it's
the doughberry yeah i know he's got a
little guy exactly
yeah it
it is [ __ ] incredible they have a
private dining room do they have
pictures of charlie chaplin around there
uh no i don't i don't know how dare you
upstairs they do they have a whole
upstairs area um it's [ __ ] beautiful
ryan real talk let's go there we will
best bread and the best butter they
import their butter from normandy i
never heard someone say
there's a whole like
when you have butter like that in
normandy they don't they let those cows
they have to eat a certain way yeah
they're on a certain slope
the [ __ ] companion because i i was
literally about to pass oh yeah i didn't
eat all day and then i was like man
would y'all have some barbecue and stuff
yeah i might get a barbecue yeah some
burbank place it was nice though huh
that barbecue [ __ ] yeah that was growing
huh
yeah you straight up [ __ ] tough
mudder straight to companion yeah it's
so fun though drinking whiskey and just
talking oh yeah like you know what i
mean i was just sitting there going this
is such a blast we're watching fights
and we're hanging out and being the
longest companion we've ever done at
thick white we've done longer than three
hours
remember with rogan we'd finish
companion and go he would just keep
going and you and i were like trying to
get out of there yeah and he'd be like
man let's
store some pizza like dude it's fun
a.m let's go eat steak i was like wow
everything's closed
that's funny force them to open then
we'd go eat yeah the rogan just killed
like the fights were down but okay that
was fun
no doubt so anyway you're like
he can go he can go that long and not go
not not take a bathroom break
he's a camel it's unbelievable
those were huge the reason that
the biggest yeah
the best which i never really thought
about when i was doing them not at the
time we're just having fun yeah yeah
i wish i get eddie to do one he just
won't do anything publicly anymore why
really just doesn't he just doesn't want
the attention and yeah
you know i always liked when he got on
stage
yeah he's
great i've seen him in a long time no me
neither talk about his gyms are crushing
it yeah i mean an iconic that's always
focused on his gym then i know he was
going to leave l.a but can you have so
many gyms there he couldn't yeah
but i know if they were if they were
going to force vaccinations on kids he
was going to leave but they most of his
gyms are here
he's home because he has them all over
right i sent you that article on uh
on how they did this meta-analysis okay
the economists at university of chicago
that just different academics who don't
have a group yeah are extra ground and
they looked at mortality rates with
severe lockdown states that had severe
lockdown okay where they shut everything
down california new york california new
jersey then you take florida they didn't
right they had it open so all the states
had severe lockdowns did they did it
have an effect on mortality rates no the
answer is no florida did better less
people died in florida per capita
per capita than in california okay and
and yet florida and the kids
they they were they got to go to school
their economy didn't crash or anything
yeah they're economies we in california
finished i think 47th in economy
50th in education where the kids my kids
didn't get to go to school
okay we're in masks the whole time uh
and and and well-being well-being was
[ __ ] so it's in every one of these
states like california and [ __ ] new
jersey
and yes so let me ask you something
because people try to argue save lives
well i guess yeah
those are smaller because i've heard
people try to argue like oh well there's
more people in california
they adjusted they adjusted they
adjusted
and florida is very dense so
especially miami yeah and they were 20
they were 24th inning of mortality and
and everybody else was california was
way higher and new york forget it yeah
so it's a nightmare yeah so so you
didn't save lives but you did destroy
economies you didn't double down on it
yeah still double down there's no they
still yeah they won't look at that they
won't look at the stats and they keep
saying they can't cause their egos they
can't because they they can't admit that
they're wrong because then people can be
really mad so they just double down on
it but then when midterms come we'll see
what's pop keep that same energy keep
that same
it goes down to when you give a federal
bureaucracy the washington dc that much
power to dictate that's why this country
was a federation right it's like a
federalist country where states have
their have rights and states can set
their own policy that's a beautiful
thing but we never want to have
washington get all that power bad
[ __ ] idea my boy in sweden he said
they never shut down anything no they
didn't look at their mortality rates
they questioned it way less
more land but yeah per kappa if when
they do per capita there was a way
smarter way to do things
way smarter yeah the only defense there
for if there's defensive rating they
the problem is they're double down it
now but they would go we just didn't
know at the time we thought that was the
best course of action but we kind of did
know florida did know you know utah did
know idaho didn't yeah and all of this
was no one but no one you know let's
give people but i'd say no one knew
right but to be fair to them like no one
knows like i honestly
they're don't get wrong they are the
worst i i i i like your i like what
you're saying even
like fauci triggers me triggers me yeah
to his defense that at the time no one
kind of knew and they thought it was
gonna get worse i thought that this can
kill way more people even though it's
killed a million people my my issue is
not in their point of view or opinion my
issue is in when you give federal
bureaucrats at the level of washington
that much power how much power it's not
you're never giving it back yeah once
you give it you can't knock the
toothpaste back in the bottle correct
that's my issue with yeah yeah well
that's what my boys swear and now these
comes in a tube but i know yeah i said
bob you confused genie with toothpaste
and you do it all the time and i like
that no but you did see this where you
[ __ ] gone with that because my
toothpaste comes in a box i didn't know
that now are you saying that's the
charcoal bottle okay are you sure yeah
you hit the button it comes do you
promise i promise all right my son also
has the crest that comes in the box so
you're you're doubling down on the glass
bottle yeah listen i know i make a lot
of mistakes this one i'm not
listen i like that you double down and
you invented that you're killing some
ice christian he's got a drink now
um but
to your point be but so i forgive him at
the start okay we didn't know you should
look lock us down all good i'm with you
man yeah let's figure this out yeah but
you did figure it out and you didn't
release the news to us and you double
down on lockdown yeah that's when i go
oh you're a bad guy yeah that's when i'm
out like they couldn't who didn't admit
the [ __ ] up well you didn't they didn't
mention that obesity and diabetes was
the number one
comorbidities that made you die they
never said that if you're a healthy
person and you're not obese and you
don't have uh you know onset diabetes
you're not chances are very very rare
that you would die
we're not saying anything that the
public doesn't doesn't know even
democrats hardcore democrats like we did
not handle this right we [ __ ] up all
right and i'm cool which is fair but
it's the leader just admit
see that's what boy in sweden said he
said they didn't make it about politics
or anything like that i don't feel like
they're all just like on the same page
like i think that that a lot of the far
left or a lot of democrats are making
the mistake that to think that americans
care more about biological males and
sports if you're defending that over
like our livelihood the economy
education that that's that's a big
mistake well there's more than we're
going to learn the hard work yeah the
most americans once these elections come
up they're going to win
the best of ways yeah and i can't wait
i
have a
countdown clock at my house i can't wait
yeah
yeah i don't forget these things no
never mm-hmm how could you yeah
yeah a lot of uh thanks buddy there it
is
there's tiger thick dude we just got we
just got into california distribution
california
texas we're all over at specs
we're in 30
cities now
distribution real beast real beasts yeah
it's almost everything with alcohol i
heard everything it's all about
distribution that's why conor sold for
so much because whoever he partnered
with had distribution off the bat
worldwide you need distribution you have
to have distribution depend what you
want to do and there are like four
companies that do it right like and
they've been doing for hundreds of years
it's a good old boys club yes it is
you're not in unless you
every club i go available buys it now so
that's cool like it'll be in phoenix
thank you brother i have to have let me
have a little sip of that let me give it
a taste test now let me have it put your
old lips on that dude yeah drink it like
that come on man like a like a rockstar
deep deep throat that bottle deep throat
it daddy you won't deep thought it daddy
smooth let it
go down the esophagus that's a nice
whiskey yeah thanks sir smooth and it's
smooth that's a nice whiskey smooth jazz
smoothie
japanese and bourbon
a little combo the only one there is
god damn i could drink more
yeah me too i gotta work out though you
know work out you're working you're
working out after this dude how about
there was a guy at the tough mudder this
guy goes anybody wants shrooms
matt goes y'all take him we go no you're
not
hold on no you're not because you're
doing if he goes oh yeah i forgot we
gotta work out this oh yeah don't be on
shrooms you'd be exhausted by the time
you get to the gym matt goes yeah you're
right i'm gonna i'm gonna pass this time
the guy takes him
30 minutes into it we're running through
this little like stream rock here and he
goes shrooms are kicking in
and then 10 minutes later
disappeared
went into the mountain i don't know what
happened i don't know if he's still on
the mountain he's living with them never
heard from him another guy behind me
goes yeah man shrooms are a bad idea i
go what who in the [ __ ] i told you my
friend took shrooms in mexico so he
starts cramping because and then because
mark knows the body really well mark
goes dude that thing's going to
dehydrate you make sure you're getting
electrolytes the guy goes really it
dehydrates you mark goes yes dude make
sure you get electrolytes in dude and
the guy started cramping he started
throwing up well i told you my buddy we
were in mexico for his 50th birthday and
he decided to take shrooms with a young
lady
and she probably didn't take him he got
lost in the mexican desert and they had
to find him with a golf cart the next
morning we woke up and goes where is he
and then he came back covered in cactus
quills and bug bites
oh he was naked that guy on the top on
glenn helen raceway probably [ __ ] i
don't know
i'm telling you didn't finish the race
that's so [ __ ] just disappear
psychedelics with a long endurance race
and he took him right when we started
then goes 30 minutes shrooms are getting
angry what happened i'm not going to say
his name what happened there
i have no idea was he in the background
no
i'm like he just disappeared yeah that's
the shroom's daddy oh my god i mean who
just shroomed through i climbed a
mountain on a lot of shrooms a big
whiskey mountain in utah i don't know
why you don't do that oh dude yeah why
yeah why i need a little i was saying i
didn't make you want to do that or i go
to my buddy i go hey you stop it go you
got to move at the mountain he goes what
he goes we got to move with the mountain
because there you see the rocks are
coming in it doesn't make sense and it
made no sense
i'll tell you what nothing's better when
you finish that tough mudder those nine
something miles and they give you a cold
course light
daddy i don't know they had those fish
my favorite one wasn't there the hot dog
with the wrap bacon was oh yeah i was
banking on eating that they had barbecue
which was fine you need that you need
those carbs as cold carbs those fizzy
carbs i still didn't do carbs but i did
i did drink the beer that was my carbs
man light-headed driving home whatever
yeah but that's nice did you eat after
that a little bit
barely i didn't feel like eating
no because you said you're here right i
got to the companion i was so lucky did
you come straight from the race right to
the companion i had 30 minutes i went
home changed and then came here wow
did mark right out there with you
no because because i took the bronco and
there's only oh and then he rode with
homeboy the chiropractor who moved out
here good kid though yeah yeah he's a
good dude really nice all right what do
you got jim
i feel like you could do a 5k chin
once i get surgery i'll do all that
stuff oh do you think you have to have
surgery now most likely yeah you have to
have the algorithm in surgery of surgery
i've been i'm talking to
even my dad and my brothers my brother's
friends and
yeah most likely is it bothering you
right now you seem all right i got the
cortisone shot so it's it's helping a
little bit
but i'm taking pain medicine all the
time so i can't you know yeah
did you go to a doctor who said
you need surgery
all my doctors yeah i assume it's legal
dude but i mean like over
down on
[Music]
that you never work out and decided to
have a wrestling yeah he's right on this
reminder i blew my hammings out but um
also you're not wearing the neck brace
anymore chin at home i do
it's not it's not really a brace it's a
traction device so it pushes your head
up against your shoulder why don't you
wait here anymore that's hilarious i
mean it doesn't have like a pump where
you can like yeah you pump it up yeah
yeah i see you remember
my neck couldn't be more sore i was
doing when you play volleyball you're
doing this the whole time you're staring
up [ __ ] dude you're building your your
your neck muscles too though aren't you
maybe oh that's all i do it doesn't
really help
well what else you got to all right
uh
let's start with i wish i had bigger
but not that one oh that's there we go
so last week jimmy kimmel made a joke on
a show about the
uh one of the representatives of atlanta
and i guess she saw it she was very
upset by it and she decided to make a
police report about jimmy kimmel making
a joke about her
and this is the joke they just voted for
kbj wow where is will smith when you
really need him huh
saying's gonna like you want will smith
and people i think it's interesting that
she had made a police report about this
saying that this was threatening to her
life when there's video of her telling
people that they should kill nancy
pelosi for treatment she's an [ __ ]
she's a huge [ __ ]
and and and they're saying that they're
pro-pedophile because uh kenji brown oh
let that guy out yeah but it's a way
more complicated than that the case was
more complicated i don't know the
details but this is what this is what
politics do whether you're republican or
democrat they harp on one
[ __ ] one thing a long time ago and
you know it's it's like this is the
point but she's
he put officer i'd like to report a joke
you double down on it that's funny
that's hilarious
so this is a really sad one i don't know
too many of the details but nfl's dwayne
haskins uh was found dead at 24 after
being struck by a dump truck and you
know matt lived in florida for a long
time and he goes oh he because i go why
would be jogged on a highway matt goes
no there's just one road they consider a
highway but everyone walks down it he
was on a straight up highway interstate
595 really and was
walking across and tried crossing over
and got hit by a dump truck yeah they're
currently investigating to see if it was
like him trying to
kill himself that way
but we're still not sure what's
happening it's all very important that's
what it felt like it's terrible and then
he he posted something to his girl right
before this uh yeah it's all such a
[ __ ] so it could it feels like that's
what it is what he said was girl i don't
know he proposed to her recently
oh they got married too
yeah but that doesn't mean anything
people
it's horrible man that's terrible it
really is man
oh
yeah it's a bummer man
yeah why the [ __ ] was he running down
[ __ ] the interstate yeah it was very
early in the morning
and also with him like he's a smart
athletic smart dude like
getting hit by because it's not like a
small car flying at 100 miles an hour
yeah a dump truck something something
was going on something's fishy there
something special yeah i feel like they
said the guy who hit him stayed after
yeah it felt awful yeah please report
like so that's probably traumatized too
it feels like it
i don't know but it just feels like a
suicide yeah honestly horrible horrible
horrible it sucks
all right
so there are twitter employees who are
currently panicking now that elon musk
has is the single largest stock owner
where they are
trying to redo their resumes because
they don't want to work for
those poor things it must be so hard for
them to work at twitter
their lives are so hard
oh they're i mean but you know
they're upset because he's yeah yeah
he's gonna do freedom but he wants
freedom of speech yeah what gave the
hold on the thing about this thing about
this hold on you're upset that elon musk
doesn't give freedom a speech but you're
to work for a company
that condones the silencing of saying
it's misinformation of covid
misinformation of people that don't
agree with home girl or homeboy racing
against girls yeah i'm saying you're
going to silence those
then you're going to silence people that
said it was it came from a lab like
trump and stuff you know silence those
people and then you're going to say
you're for free speech
and then elon musk comes along and goes
i want everybody to say where the [ __ ]
they were and now you're going to but
these design from twitter people
yeah but the people in big tech these
activists and they are you're supposed
to bring your authentic self to work you
know that movement bring your
authenticity to work so what happens is
you get people that are complete
activists that are working they're not
doing any work and they they basically
you know these are not people that have
ever think about it they went to elite
yeah they don't live ivy league schools
no they've never then they went right
into the most pressure journalists the
most privileged and so they so things
are hard elon musk or when when they
were trying to publish jordan peterson's
book people were crying
they were crying in the editing room
they were like we can't but this he's he
hates trans people and they were crying
well this is so hard
it was so insane do you think about the
soy boys that and and girls soy boys and
girls
and whoever else at spotify because
rogan came there fire them just get them
the [ __ ] out of there get them out of
there you're you don't even you're so
[ __ ] dumb you're so ignorant to
history and more importantly you're so
ignorant to what got you here that
allows you to speak the way you think
about in your spoiled world the reason
you haven't been punched in the face or
whatever is because of the system that
you are criticizing it's unbelievable
man you think about resign dying on the
hill that you want freedom of speech but
then you want to you literally work for
a company that's silence people that
doesn't agree with the it's amazing
national agenda it's amazing it doesn't
make any how stupid there's no
consistency they're not they're not
thoughtful they're eating their own tail
what else you got can we get a light
that doesn't make me look this bald i
changed
[Laughter]
no just embrace you look like [ __ ] first
of all how do you know you look bad like
man i mean that's how you look dude look
we're looking at the screen
that looks good
let me see
just take this i'm disgusting
the whole thing's a bummer you look like
a third base coach it's getting older
buddy yeah yeah you just gotta just
double down on it dude
my father-in-law looked at me and goes
whoa
that's not nice what and he goes you're
gray i was like huh
okay
uh next uh event all right here we go
okay this is a really weird one there it
is we believe it oh i don't i don't know
let's see a 57 year old australian man
went to his doctor because he had some
pains in his groin area the doctor
inspected it and said like oh you should
be fine here's some medicine and he kept
feeling this immense pain so he rushed
to the er and said
oh i think my doctor had misdiagnosed me
and they found out that the doctor did
misdiagnose him because he didn't pull
back his foreskin to see what the actual
issue was and the doctor at the er said
you have such
terrible hygiene to the point where your
pubic hair is matted and it's like
cutting off the circulation
what the [ __ ] hold on but mental illness
but what kind of jumanji pubes this guy
who's obviously crazy and was twirling
his hair around his dick did he say he
was a homeless guy he did not say he was
a of course he was a homeless guy i'm
sorry i'm in the house i meant on the
house
i hate you ryan
he didn't clean underneath the hood yeah
so he's not cleaning his penis properly
and the doctor said you're gonna have to
have surgery to fix this we gotta
basically like take the skin back you
gotta clean it out make sure
everything's good he freaked out at the
thought of having surgery that he
actually left the hospital didn't come
back but two weeks later his penis hurt
so bad he came back got the surgery and
while he was recovering he was supposed
to stay a few days longer but he
actually bailed yeah and you know
yeah right
but i don't i think they probably did
remove it but then he was after the
surgery he didn't keep up with the
maintenance of keeping it clean so he
came back after he left the hospital i
mean it's not
like
his [ __ ] kind of that's what it seems
yeah boys you know like we don't have
point for like
these eggs
off his foreskin chin chabelle you guys
pull that wizards i told you it's like
there's not
that wizard
wizard hat there you clean it
i mean don't get me wrong i'm wearing a
[ __ ] ring right now but it fits and it
it it's expanding and he didn't shave
his freaking that's what i'm saying
yeah this is [ __ ] he's crazy has no
one taught him how to take care of his
dick i feel like sometimes like men just
don't know you gotta pull it back you
haven't might be a little crazy a little
homeless okay he didn't have a home you
think he's worried about his dick yeah
he wouldn't stay in the hospital but
chen chabelle you guys have hoods you
you pull that thing back let it air out
every now and then
oh you've got a whole question
yeah
we discussed this before brian
let it air out a little bit i got to
clean it out just let it in every now
and then it's on a summer day it's nice
to just pull it back yeah pull it back
in the breeze i'd get a few rings
get a few rays
get some of that vitamin c yeah
what would you do
no no i'm gonna give them some orange
juice
double
yeah as soon as i clean it that dried
off really really well yeah yeah
with the towel yeah when you dry it off
if you pat drivers
you do something like this
oh yeah oh yeah you ring it out you put
it you put it back in the kangaroo pouch
yeah i got it you got a ring dry i gotta
make sure everything's dry and good to
go you got a big old thick head on him
doorknob head
how big how big you're definitely not a
doorknob he had a piss hole on you yeah
satoshi
diamond shape this hole huh what a
diamond shaped pistol no mine looks like
a regular but you got you got you ever
worry about you get nervous about the
hood having the hood after hearing stuff
like this yeah no no because we went six
hours yeah you take showers
yeah you do though we gotta worry about
you know if there's some residue like
some soap in there yes you do no you
just i mean
just
asking questions bro i know but it's
just like it's fun
it's kind of conversational if you have
it you know how to [ __ ] clean it yeah
you pull back this guy back
in relation to the elon musk thing i
just saw this today
even though he's
dirty dingles there he's not joining the
board apparently according to the ceo
ceo says this for the best
so he's not joining that's what he's
saying ceo
i feel like indian people
are super smart and are running all the
[ __ ] tech industries
he still has a voice but he's not free
speech officially joining the border
patrol
economy yeah you believe twitter is here
no
good
yeah who would
alrighty
um
this is a pretty crazy one
it's still being investigated because
they don't know what started this one
yeah they don't know what started this
bad call i mean that's most likely that
yeah but yeah yeah but there's nothing
uh official yet
i was so [ __ ] pissed they all jump
them yeah well one side even the other
team not one team no one team
okay that poll is definitely in the way
so these guys are like walking up right
here
are those guys players yeah no uh two of
them are the others aren't
they're all get them
and then look at it he lays one of them
poor kid watch poor man he lays one of
them out like [ __ ]
but the referee's friends are fellow
reptiles
yeah no one's helping him and they knock
them out no they don't knock him out
but he gets down though he gets knocked
down gosh i want to kick those [ __ ]
kids ass i know you see this rough he's
just chilling oh yeah that's not cool
look at that ref uh the female oh
[Laughter]
three seconds in the paint on that ass
yeah right
so 30 stitches you had to get i'm not
doing it intentional foul whoops no that
makes me mad i want to doesn't make you
mad that's why you got some pepper spray
well i'm not even worried about her or
him that her ass was out of control oh
it was am i right three seconds i didn't
you didn't see her brian dude
intentional foul too much ass all right
come on you're bullied
hold on technical foul all right man
right now i got to find her
i'm not falling for that stuff the
watcher comes here right around here
there she is let me see jesse goes in to
help where dude the only there we go
there we go yeah
technical foul too much ass now what
kind of trouble do these kids get into a
shitload i don't think anything happens
to him yeah no updates as of yet they
probably missed the next game at the
ymca well they're not allowed at this
place anymore obviously seriously that's
one thing yeah that's actually
background is that a church by the way
with little [ __ ]
and high school kids uh are [ __ ] i
spo i played volleyball yesterday with
three high school kids that were
210 pounds each the [ __ ] huge i was
like jesus christ if i was in high
school i'd get the [ __ ] kicked out of me
i'd be bullied
the [ __ ] huge these kids what'd you
wear in high school you were skinny
190. yeah big graduated like 200. these
kids were all football players big boys
why are you playing with high school
kids though
hey kevin
spacey you don't have any other friends
they were around you saw them yeah hey
fellas they were in shorts and you
invited them to play can you guys spike
a ball do you guys want to play
volleyball with old uncle bry
spike these nuts in your butt and all
right
it was so weird out there like we're in
high school y'all are [ __ ] nuts
[Laughter]
i was like what the [ __ ] they were
shaved down no they had the [ __ ]
they had to shave bro
they were young men is what i'm trying
to say dude
that would have kicked your ass we we
brought people in then i bring in these
these dudes from gardena and the eric
and shout out to eric and irving who
listen to the podcast all the time i've
watched every [ __ ] episode they were
like brian kellen i was like come play
[ __ ] volleyball we had a [ __ ]
blast i played with high school kids
gosh martina and just having a barbecue
after hey we needed more people
out there do you
shave down high school kids and two
random fans i didn't say shave down yeah
i said they have to shave dude you said
they shaved me out no i never said that
you gave me i never said
i just what i didn't say i said what i
won't do i say in your volleyball no i
said that they were they were they were
very mature young man and they played
with uncle brian that's all you haven't
seen his promo video you guys want to
play volleyball you guys i thought you
were going to play handball with them or
spike ball you only need four people
with volleyball you need a little more
so i tend to recruit people
you guys want to play
do you guys want to play with us
it works every time yeah
what else you got jim
all right you guys mentioned dk metcalf
before yeah he's afraid uh his diet's
not yeah so he's got a better body than
me apparently he has one meal a day one
coffee and like three or four bags of
candy he's a big gummy fish wait what
that's what he says to find bags of
candy dk matt dk metcalf has an absurd
diet
absurd diet one meal one coffee three to
four bags of cane per day stats six
three 228 pounds 1.6 uh body fat
obviously not accurate that can't be
real no right but his 40 and everything
else is no i'm not i'm not talking about
it no he's probably diet seven percent
body fat no that's his diet four or
three yeah that's his that's he's on the
right yeah i like it there's no [ __ ]
way really there's a ton of guys who eat
tons of kids he's a freak of all freaks
he's got world-class speeds one meal one
coffee he said defined bags of cake i
mean he also eats other food i mean you
know he's eating everything
no he's not no he says he only eats one
meal a day he goes through the whole
thing and he has a cup of coffee listen
i don't eat anything really till
damn near one like today i had food at
12 15 but
a lot of people do that they fast all
morning i'm sure i'm saying he eats a
meal i'm sure he doesn't know he says
that stuff like that yeah no that's what
he says but he eats
three to four bags of candy too that's
not his whole meal he's just saying
right he has one meal and on top of that
he has three to four bags of candy he
likes gummies
that's insane i [ __ ] stephen ella
who's who does alpine hunting like he's
up in the mountains and like it's six
days of hell you're walking all the time
and i said what do you eat you know and
he goes candy
i go what he goes i eat my meal and i
eat a lot of candy it makes my body feel
good when i'm up there like i need the
sugar
but you're they're burning off he's
burning off obviously yeah could get
dicey for him when he's like 60 you know
stop playing i think when you're burning
that kind of when you're that physical
all the time you can eat anything you
want i think his body he's just a
complete freak yes he's also he could
eat whatever yes
what else you got jen yes all right
this here
so you know locked down in shanghai is
hardcore they have like zero zero like
positive test rule
right yeah they're trying to completely
get rid of it people are committing
suicide jumping out yeah china sucks so
there's some videotape this is what
happens when governments get that much
power it could happen anywhere
apparently so everyone's locked in their
apartments in the high-rise and then
they're screaming right now
no leaving your apartment for any reason
[Applause]
i don't know how much i trust these
videos because we saw the ones remember
people falling down and children putting
electricity
verified it's authentic here's my thing
dude
you're all mean imagine not being able
to leave your [ __ ] house dude oh is
it not healthy for people yeah people go
nuts look at this here too so this is a
drone
that's saying what you see here please
comply with kobe restrictions control
your soul's desire for freedom do not
open the window or sing holy [ __ ]
there's drones right there
this is what these this is what
governments do that's [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's called tyranny you want china you
want that cool we watch
yeah far left watch us go yeah i know
buddy goes let me get my dick yeah they
want that a lot of people and a lot of
people want total oh that's that's
exactly what when you give government
that kind of people
this is how this goes what happens
that's the end of this movie that's
because
history
shows you that that's what happened
yeah yeah
that's unbelievable a [ __ ] drone
telling you i know don't sing or open
your window you [ __ ] man and
they listen they have to they'll go to
jail if they don't or die here's the
last one this is sexy amma
and i guess his back or
just check out his back here
hell yeah who is that guy fighter that's
mark harley
all right
it's mark harley oh he's that fighter
the japanese korean one
aoki
oh he looks jacked he dresses so well
too has an ass on him for nate he's got
an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and it's always men it's always men
asians yes like filipino men dump trucks
really yeah they're usually shorter
though yeah yeah that's good no some of
these people
now that's all natural
i don't know i don't know
he fights in one championship yeah he's
fighting ufc he's been all over
his stud dress is great that's him right
there he does he lives he's actually
he's actually [ __ ] awesome and i
forgot about him you know he sings in
huge arenas yes he's sold out arena what
he's amazing he's actually who all of us
should aspire to be
taking easy there's him in 2015
holy [ __ ] he is so [ __ ] jacked this
is his gold skin that does it for beam
oh man
how old is he look at him there he'll
kick your wall
40 seconds yeah is he for 47 or 49 yeah
47 like that god dude
he just fought his style too so sick i
love this outfit
his outfit is sick dude
how do you say his name
yoshihiro akiyama yeah i i am an
assassin
i'm going to ask a question and i mean
it with respect sure is he gay
seriously he's very looking yeah i just
think he might he just he has that vibe
which i know he's like his kids and a
wife he has a wife he's awesome
yeah look at him he's a handsome [ __ ]
he's korean and japanese
[ __ ] stud that's his daughter right
there yeah oh he's just kids and a wife
his mom's right there sorry no i i don't
thought he was scared how did you get
gay out of that yeah i don't know he's
just showing he reminds me of
no i'm sorry uh
who is an author
he had that same style all right help me
with the name yeah who's the guy
yeah but i'm saying he was that style of
guy and he would dress like that and he
committed suicide yeah man he killed he
committed uh harry kerry in like on he
took over the japanese defense forces he
wanted to bring japan back he wanted to
bring way of the warrior back he was a
[ __ ] amazing writer yeah held him for
hostage and then actually committed
seppuku sure hey you know he doesn't
look like sexy um though yeah yeah uh
he's
same style
same style he had a flare for that
dramatic that's all like look at that he
just doesn't look like him they'll be he
might have look like yes
come on before steroids dude it's his
face though it's the issue yeah but then
sex young's face is gorgeous yeah this
dude just games
that's a gay
japanese man is he japanese yes
that name is very japanese face looks
very chinese though am i right jin no i
gotta say it looks does look more
chinese you are getting better yes thank
you brandon what the [ __ ] he's talking
about he's very japanese
dude comparing him to sexy you know
that's offensive well i bet you the sexy
army wouldn't wouldn't
a great writer phenomenal writer very
very much about style but very gay
talked about the underground look at
who's that
he's from fast and furious he was the
johnny tran in the first movie some guy
too beautiful man no you know he's a
dime piece the guy who was in uh [ __ ]
uh squid game who who got him into the
game in the suit oh yeah oh that guy
was like slapping him oh my god i love
him
let me see we had about five minutes of
air time but he'll steal your heart let
me see that guy he was the one that was
slapping him right like yeah he lost
that guy what did nobody like sex he got
picked up by netflix recently that guy
yes him no i don't i don't agree with
you i think he's so handsome what's his
name yeah
oh the main character looks like when he
was younger was it looks like he's heard
compared to [ __ ] sexy
you guys know what i'm saying yeah i
mean everybody looks like a turd
compared to sexy yama dude
what a stud who else were you talking
about
the main guy in uh squid games when he
was younger he was such
a handsome man like really heartthrob
yeah
great when he was young the girl from it
needs to eat huh she's at the oscars
like god damn girl
yeah well she was a model
she's a model i feel like oh he was yeah
dude very good yeah
yeah
gary btk
he looks good now there
great actor they're doing squid game too
i assume yeah they are yeah i believe so
i don't know where the story is the
director was talking about every his
family asked for money he's like i
didn't make money on this like it was
the debut he's like now the second part
yeah i'll make money now i'm not making
much money yeah
same thing with some of the actors from
euphoria a lot of people thought that
they would pop off and be really rich
coming to this day is making the most
money yeah people who already had a
established career like zendaya sydney
sweeney they're making a bunch they're
making money but everyone else who just
got discovered they're barely really but
they i mean they will now they will now
it's like the guy uh
the white drug dealer his name is angus
cloud yeah he uh did an interview with
the
ah theo's boy uh simon rex oh yeah okay
yeah they were talking about how people
thought he was really rich but he still
lives with a bunch of roommates in
koreatown oh wow because what happens is
when you sign on for that show you sign
a six-year contract
at a certain no matter how yeah at a
very small salary because you're nobody
knows you yeah and then you get a five
percent you kind of have to take that
contract now what you do is after when
it becomes a hit like that you get
together as a cast and you do a favored
nations deal it's always expected so you
go hey we need more money yeah but then
zunde goes nah i'm good
yeah i'm in spiderman ho that's what
happened with fresh prince because
remember they had two moms two different
people yeah two different aunt vibs yeah
two different op vibs
she was like we need more money still
like will's the start
well speaking of tough gigs i'm in uh
phoenix this thursday friday saturday
stand up live your boy is there and then
april 23rd moon tower economy festival
we moved from uh cap city to the
paramount theater one show one giant ass
show saturday night the paramount
theater austin texas moon tower comedy
festival and then charlotte north
carolina just got announced may 5th
through the 7th come get some tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com
but phoenix you're up this week thursday
friday saturday we'll also be at jt's
wings on saturday as well the special
drops april sunday drops april 23rd the
green green 23rd 28th 28th come on 23rd
and i rode with them 28th yep i'm sorry
tampa i'll be there this weekend i'll
see you friday saturday tampa improv
port charlotte florida i don't stop with
florida i come right back
sorry
hey listen it's just in fort myer not a
big deal guys getting out of there
didn't cost me thousands uh las vegas
nevada wise guys comedy club april 28th
29th 30th come get some and finally
stress factory may 5th to the 7th
but
shooting my special tickets just went on
sale brea improv uh may 19th shooting my
special with a very special special and
what i got up next uh may 6th and 7th
i'll be in san diego at a new comedy
club out there called mic drop comedy
club and then uh later down the road in
the summertime uh june 24th and 25th
i'll be in east providence rhode island
shout out to meatball at the comedy
connection
boom all right kids love ya we're out
bye